What
Was the joke that bad?
I'm gonna kill you
What?
I didn't get you said you gonna have to speak out
Not today
Not tomorrow
But I'm gonna kill you
Jesus
Simon
What he have, a knife?
Yeah , a hatchet
a hatchet?
an axe
Simon is my right-hand man
have one of those is important
I mean what I have left without one
a whole lot of work
You have one?
Maybe one of these fine people still breathing
oh
or did die?
sure
yeah
gimme his axe
I'll be right back
maybe Rick will be with me
if not, well...
we can just turn these people in that won't we
I mean
the one those are left
Hey youtubers, It's Charlie
So if you're wondering why everyone is freaking out
about this walking dead footage
is from episode 1 wich is in two weeks
but it's a big deep cut from the governor comics
so just careful for spoilers
from like the really early governor comics
in Walking Dead
so here we go
Most of you even if you haven't
read the comics
probably know what's going on in this
He is making all these right hand jokes
and you know what happened to Rick Grimes
in the comics
but that was during the governors reign
so they're kind of doing a homage to the governor
during issue 28 of the comic book
with this negan scene here
So everyone is like
wait a minute
are they gonna cut Rick hands off?
like they said they were never gonna do that
they said it was too difficult
they said it'll be too expensive to do the special effects
but then people like well
they did Hershel
they cut Hershel's legs off
so all the way up to the top
with even like Robert Kirkman going back years
have you know they've been flip-flopping
on whether or not something like that
was even possible
but the thing about that though is
is that you can't really bank
on what someone says a couple years ago
because think about how they started off doing the show
and it was almost nothing like the comics
like they had a couple comic book moments
cut a couple years later
all the way through season five, six and seven
and we've actually been following the comics pretty closely
albeit with a slightly different roster
like they had some characters that weren't in the comics
like daryl is not in the comics
so they use certain characters in a slightly different ways
but when people get killed
they still do big comic book kills
even if the characters looks little bit different
so they have big comic book moments
they're opening the season with the rest of that Negan kill
they've been teasing that even more than one person
might get killed
and this is them just teasing
hey, look: this is only the beginning
we might do the thing that you never thought
that we would do
which I think is the challenge
for the Walking Dead now
like show us something that isn't possible
you've been six years of the ultraviolent
you don't see big comic book moments
now surprise us by doing the thing
you said you were never going to do
so just explain the way it happened in the comics
this is issue 28
this is like way early on
just to give you an idea of how far we are from
Governor stuff in the comics
So the governor
like the big Rick-Governor hand moment
is an issue 28
Negan doesn't even appear
in the comics til issue 100
so we're blowing past that right here
I wouldn't be surprised if we get to all that war
by the end of this season
but they might even move that up too
See, you don't necessarily have to read along
in the comics but
if you really like to do that
it's a lot of fun
So just explained that issue 28
what happens is the Governor is seizing power
He has them at his mercy
the same way Negan has the survivors here
at his mercy
and says you don't understand the seriousness
of the situation to Rick
Rick looks like I'm gonna kill you
and boom
chops his hand right off
so Ricks wakes up in a hospital
realizes he only has one hand
but even though there's a lot of Governor dialogue
that's transposed onto Negan here
that doesn't necessarily mean that he cut his hand off
But I do think that's going to get way
worse before it gets better
That's kind of the way the Walking Dead works
like it takes you to the cliff
like at the end of last season
this pool of bloody gravel
is actually the remains of the person that Negan killed
or at least one of the people that Negan killed
if there is going to be more than one person
but then when they open each new season
they start out with kind of like the continuation of that
like just kick the energy off
like oh my god we're still in the middle of it
and then once that moment is over
you're ok, maybe we'll get a little bit of rest
but then they just jam on the gas
and it gets crazy again
so I think that's what they're trying to do in this season 7
because the audience has been in decline
just like a little bit of the last couple of seasons
The Walking Dead is still one of the most watched shows
So the challenge this season
is ain't showing you that there's still so much
left to do that's going to be really excited
that was the whole point of Robert Kirkman
introducing Negan in the comics
because they got issue 100
and people are like okay this has been cool
but it's not quite exciting anymore
and you know Robert Kirkman and Charlie Adlard
are like wait wait wait!
You know we have all this awesome stuff that's coming
so BAM
Negan drops
and shit gets crazy
so that's kind of what they're trying to do
with the TV show
Let me know in the comments
Do you think that they will actually
cut Rick's hand off
I think they can do it like
it's a lot easier to do Carl
losing the eye
because he only has to walk around
with an eye patch on
it doesn't require a lot of special effects
but they explained that doing Rick's hand
would require them doing a lot of blue and green screen
so they have to shoot it in strange ways
even Robert Kirkman was like
how is he gonna reload his gun
but here they say he has a hatchet
so there are a couple ways
to cheat it but
just remains to be seen
if they actually have the balls to go there
So everybody give them a hand
make all the hand jokes you can think of
because in two weeks episode 1 dropping
I'll be doing videos all season
so be sure to subscribe to get everything
the big thing this next week is
that we have like the four nights
of the CW superhero shows
but I'll talk about that during those videos
So walking dead and walking dead videos
Superhero comic book stuff
and the other comic book videos
Although technically, you know, walking dead is a comic book
the tone is so different from everything else
That sometimes you forget that it's a comic book
it's going to be awesome
I think this first half of the season is gonna be
really strong
but these first couple of episodes
will give you an ideia for what the pace is gonna be like
I think they're definetely picking things up
I think that's the whole ideia with Negan
While you guys wait for the post you can click here
for the full Jon Bernthal Punisher pannel
He talks a little bit about walking dead stuff
and you can click here for that iron fists trailer again
Thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys tomorrow